Cursing at children? Flashing a co-star?
Actor Tim Allen may play Santa Claus,
but co-star Casey Wilson
says he's anything but jolly.
Casey Wilson acted alongside Tim Allen in
the pilot episode of The Santa Clauses,
a Disney+ series that serves as a
sequel to Allen's three The Santa
Clause movies. On the podcast B---h
Sesh, Wilson described Allen as, quote,
"so f---ing rude." She discussed filming a scene
with the star where Santa comes down a chimney,
and Wilson's character proceeds to
throw things at him. She explained,
"He goes over to the producer who is
standing four feet from me and goes,
and I hear him, he goes, 'You gotta tell her
to stop stepping on my lines.' The producer
turns to me with horror on his face and
has to walk one foot to me and he goes,
'Um, Tim would ask that you
stop stepping on his lines.'"
As if that wasn't enough, Wilson said that at
the end of a scene, Allen loudly proclaimed
that he was leaving and dropped his cape onto
the floor for others to pick up. She concluded,
"He's a b---h. [...] I will not say who said
this. This was someone that I do not know,
perhaps in the crew. [He or she] breezes past me
and just goes, 'You're seeing him on a good day.'"
As of this video, Allen has yet to respond
to Wilson's remarks. But it would be in line
with other behind-the-scenes stories that have
come out regarding the actor over the years.
For a show about Santa Claus that airs
on Disney+, The Santa Clauses seems to
find itself mired in controversy constantly.
Viewers were annoyed by one joke in particular
in Season 1, which was clearly inspired
by a popular conservative talking point.
"Saying 'Merry Christmas to all'
has suddenly become problematic."
Now, Allen is once again in the hot
seat, and it's his alleged behavior
while filming that's put him in the line of fire.
It shouldn't exactly be news that Allen
has a short fuse. In a 2021 interview on
The Kelly Clarkson Show, Allen spoke about
an incident on the set of The Santa Clause
2 where they were shooting a scene involving a
bunch of children. A couple of the kids began
acting up and preventing them from getting
the shot they needed. As Allen put it,
"The kid said one more word, and I let out
the loudest F-bomb. And I turned around,
and there are 12 children — it looked
like you had ripped their legs off."
"Their Santa has just screamed the F-bomb."
He added that he recognized his mistake, and
even though Disney tried to do damage control,
what was done was done. But Allen's
unprofessional behavior allegedly goes
back much further — to his Home
Improvement days in the 1990s.
Pamela Anderson wrote about Allen in her memoir,
Love, Pamela, recalling an incident on the set
of Home Improvement where he allegedly
flashed his genitalia at her. Variety
published an excerpt about the incident
from the book, in which Anderson wrote,
"He opened his robe and flashed me quickly —
completely naked underneath. He said it was
only fair, because he had seen me naked.
Now we're even. I laughed uncomfortably."
Allen denied the incident
in a statement to Variety.
These accusations may explain why Hollywood
doesn't really cast Allen anymore, outside
of his main franchises like The Santa Clause. With
Season 2 of the Disney+ series wrapped, and seeing
how it hasn't been renewed for Season 3 quite
yet, it's possible that Casey Wilson's story,
as well as others concerning Allen, could convince
Disney to drop the show like a hot piece of coal.
"Merry Christmas, Sarah."